first day back at school and the prime
minister
enjoying doing something reassuringly
simple
these are some of the first students in
england to return to the class after the
summer and the prime minister is seeking
to
empathize with their plight over the
last six months
you couldn't see your teachers face to
face you couldn't sit your exams
which you yearned to do and
uh i'm afraid your your grades were uh
almost derailed by a mutant algorithm
see what he did there suggesting exam
results were about to be distorted by
a freak of nature or as the cambridge
dictionary defines it
an organism that is different from
others of its type
because of a permanent change in its
genes an unfortunate programming error
rather than the result of a request by
his government
and monitored by his ministers
somebody else's fault
but you can do a u-turn if you're
running the department for education in
england
this summer alone they've abandoned
plans to get kids back last term
abandoned the results algorithm and
abandoned initial guidance on face masks
in schools
understandably the prime minister has
concluded it's time for fresh leadership
in the department for education
but that won't mean the expulsion of
education secretary gavin williamson
instead the axe has fallen on the
department's most senior civil servant
jonathan slater and he's hardly the
first civil servant to move on quickly
in recent times
sir philip rotten pretty patel's
permanent secretary in the home office
has gone
sir richard heaton in the ministry of
justice soon to depart
says simon mcdonald also leaving dominic
raab's side in the foreign office
and the most senior civil servant of all
cabinet secretary sir mark said while
going within weeks just what do you have
to do
to be sacked in boris johnson's
government
well robert generic and priti patel and
dominic cummings and gavin williamson
all couldn't answer that question
because they've all survived the kind of
political tornado
that would have seen you out under
previous prime ministers
boris johnson doesn't believe in bowing
to pressure
he thinks it shows weakness not strength
and at the moment there's nothing to
challenge that view
apart perhaps from the labour party who
want to make this
about leadership there's been a
determined effort to offload blame in
all directions to blame the unions to
blame off qual
to blame parents that's not where the
blame lies responsibility
for coping with this crisis and
supporting schools and school leaders
sits very firmly with government
ministers and they are letting children
and young people down
permanent secretaries were called that
for a reason
part of the infrastructure of whitehall
they once saw cabinet ministers
and even government come and go
it seems things change sam coates sky
news